anna zatonski won a long end game
herself i'm going down to 67 moves
before finally putting it together anna
it seems like a tale of two tournaments
for you a little bit of a slow start but
now a couple of wins in a row
not in the royal i lost yesterday oh
sorry
i wouldn't have reminded you of that but
but you did get a couple of wins bounce
back wins uh for sure
how are you feeling about this uh this
performance
okay of course much better than in the
beginning and i don't know i hope i will
get in shape back in shape and i hope to
play we have still three more rounds
like play better than i played in the
beginning
and
i was in europe and probably it's a jet
lag and a lack of practice i have like
plenty of excuses for my performance
this game was very sharp it looked like
you were controlling the game and then
you took on g5 at some moments you got
g6 and yeah this was a mistake i just
forgot that my knight can jump not only
on e4 but on f5
so this was yeah oh i played knight f5
later in the game but at this point
somehow i just yeah forgot that i can
play knight f5 right 96 instead of
trading on on the g5 square
would have given you a strong position
you basically have stated it seems like
you're just playing for
for form now like just to keep to play
some good games yes i was like in the
beginning i was playing so fast like
even faster than anna shareevich so like
in the beginning we had like almost 20
moves and spent like 15 minutes
i think yesterday i spent like one and a
half hour on 20 moves something like
that
so that i decided to play just fast and
just make sure that i'm not blundering
anything all right well that's worked
out for you we'll let you get your rest
we know it's been a long day and the
rest day tomorrow as well yeah it's good
yeah enjoy your rest day
anna
and what
do we